good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight did you watch the State
of the Union Address last night we do
not blame you if you took a pass on that
tuning in was a grim task 80 year old
Joe Biden shuffling stiff-legged and
bewildered to the podium a husk held
together by Botox and enough
amphetamines from the White House doctor
to read the slogans written for him by
unelected Obama acolytes who actually
run the government this is our president
ladies and gentlemen
it's always pretty hard to believe when
you see it the whole scene is so awful
so degrading to our once proud country
it cannot end soon enough
but the moment was we will confess at
times pretty amusing at one point the
eminent TV doctor Dr Jill who really
ought to have her own show on Bravo
dispensing sassy and empowering medical
advice walked over to Kamala Harris's
husband Doug enhoff and kissed him
deeply Square in the mouth without a
mask something that never ever happens
at his house
what was that about
there was an unmistakable 1970s Suburban
Connecticut tea party vibe to it kind of
a John shiver story old school stuff
except
they let bystanders film the whole thing
so clearly these people are
exhibitionists too not tea
there's a lot going on behind the scenes
in the bite Administration a lot of
which we don't want to know more about
but where do these people find the time
for hijinks
Dr Jill for example is extremely
extremely busy way busier than you are
according to her husband Dr Jill is
working day and night to drag this
country out of its medieval ignorance
and that's not an easy task watch
Joe my wife who teaches full-time has an
expression
I hope I get it right kid
any nation that out educates us is going
to out-compete us
wait a second Dr Jill is teaching quote
full time how many hours a week is full
time and where is this happening what
school or University or madrasa is she
teaching at what is she teaching can we
sign up for her class how come we didn't
know any of this until last night
any nation that out educates us is going
to out-compete us as Dr Jill and that's
a fair point today is the first day of
the rest of your life Bravo Dr Jill
Bravo
the question is how shall we as a nation
respond to Dr Jill's Clarion call for
action
obviously you need to shut down the
schools for an entire year because
unionized teachers feel like longer
vacations and then get rid of all
standardized tests because racism
that's the solution it turns out that Dr
Jill who like an awful lot of Community
College Geniuses from Delaware who
received Advanced degrees in quote
education
she's an awful lot of good ideas we had
to listen to her more unfortunately we
don't often get the chance because she's
always teaching
so that really was the highlight of the
evening Dr Jill making out with the vice
president's husband and then Joe Biden
bragging about a job she doesn't
actually have pretty hard not to find
that funny
and then there was Biden himself now the
president's mental condition is either
scary and depressing deeply alarming or
absolutely hilarious depending upon your
mood last night for lack of other
entertainment options we decided to find
it funny
so take in this steaming pile of word
puree and see if you can make sense of
it
as we made clear last week if China
threatens our sovereignty we will act to
protect our country and we did
but in the past two years democracies
have become stronger not weaker
autocracy has grown weaker not stronger
name me a world leader
who changed places with Xi Jinping name
me one
name me one
we shot down their balloon so named me a
world leader who can decipher what Joe
Biden just said name me one see you
can't friends democracy is winning
tonight
now we have no idea what any of that
means any more than Xi Jinping does but
the train seals in the crowd loved it
they clapped consistent with their
species
actually sorry that is unfair to seals
there's not a seal in the ocean or even
at Sea World Who would wear an I love
abortion pin that is too low even for
marine mammals they may eat live fish
but they're not ghouls Congressional
Democrats by contrast are ghouls take a
look at this pin which has replaced the
American flag on their lapels notice
that the O in abortion is in the shape
of a heart
they literally love abortion
now let's set aside the politics and ask
an honest question who loves abortion
honestly who loves abortion maybe you
think abortion should be legal
but do you love abortion do you think
abortion is a wonderful affirming act
you feel so proud of you brag about it
with jewelry
if you feel that way you should know
that you are not defending a medical
procedure you wouldn't say that about an
appendectomy no you are promoting an
ancient religious right called Human
Sacrifice that's what this is promoting
Human Sacrifice let's stop lying about
it it's very obvious now
and speaking of death Cults Joe Biden
made his case last night for the sexual
mutilation of children
it's also passed the bipartisan equality
act to ensure LPG lgbtq Americans
especially transgender young people can
live with safety and dignity
first you want to say whoa whoa pause Mr
President Define every letter in the
acronym and what they all mean of course
he couldn't
but he is pointing to an occurring
reality in our country there are
hospitals in the United States hard as
it is to believe that are right now
performing mastectomies on little girls
in the name of gender ideology they're
castrating children and then giving them
drugs that produce sterility and
osteoporosis and they're bragging about
it
now this has happened with adults for a
long time it's never happened at scale
with children and no one's ever bragged
about it but the Democratic party now is
not just endorsing it not just
supporting it silently by calling it
unaffirmative good Joe Biden the guy who
showered with his daughter causing her
to develop sexual compulsions as an
adult cause calls the sexual mutilation
of children safety and dignity
that's dark really dark
but it got worse actually the humor
stopped and the Darkness descended Joe
Biden proceeded to talk about the recent
death of Tyree Nichols in Memphis now
you'll remember that he was killed by
five police officers all of whom were
black as was he
so the takeaway from that episode may be
worth knowing about but it has nothing
to do with race at least not directly
everyone was the same color
and yet last night Joe Biden used that
sad episode with Tyree Nichols family
present in the room to advance the LIE
the one you hear so often that the white
middle class is the single greatest
threat to America and especially to
black people watch this
most of us in here
have never had to have the talk
the talk that brown and black parents
have had to have with their children Bo
Hunter Ashley my children
I never had to have the talk with him
I never had to tell them if a police
officer pulls you over turn your
interior lights on right away
don't reach for your license
keep your hands on the steering wheel
imagine having to worry like that every
single time
your kid got in a car
now it is fair that they don't worry
like that in the Biden family both of
Biden's surviving children have had
run-ins with the piece police repeatedly
Hunter Biden left a crack pipe and his
ID in a rental car but no one ever
followed up on it because he was the son
of a powerful politician
maybe Joe Biden should be grateful for
that but it's not a racial issue but
he's saying that it is the police
African Americans are trying to murder
you because you're black that's unifying
the country police are responsible for
all the violence in Black communities
that's his message
now that is not only a lie provably a
lie because reliable statistics exist
it's a lie that's caused a lot of people
including a lot of black Americans to
die over the last three years because
police in many places have stopped
enforcing the law and in others have
simply quit and they're replaced by
total mediocrities and crazy violent
people like the cops who beat Tyree
Nichols to death in Memphis how do you
think they got that job
because normal people quit that's why
because they didn't want to work in an
industry that's under attack unfairly
from the president United States
and now Joe Biden is repeating that lie
and on and on and on at one point he
claimed January 6th was
active Insurrection and that it was an
insurrectionist not a hippie nudist with
a BLM sign outside his home who attacked
Paul Pelosi last year do you remember
that
the last few years our democracy has
been threatened and attacked put at risk
put to the test In This Very Room on
January the 6th and then just a few
months ago
an unhinged big lie
a sale and Unleashed a political
violence the home of the then Speaker of
the House of Representatives
using the very same language the
insurrectionists used as they stalk
these halls and chanted on January 6th
the insurrectionists people who were
justly upset because they felt that the
2020 election was not on the level which
it was not by the way which it was not
and we know that for a fact
now that we've seen the Google the
Twitter files which prove that the big
tech companies took a side in that
election we didn't have a free and fair
election certainly not a free press
but people were upset about that are now
insurrectionists non-violent protesters
or insurrectionists etc etc etc and the
lies just kept coming to the point where
it was deeply frustrating to watch at
one point Biden claimed that NATO was
fighting against Putin's aggression even
though we now know thanks to the Israeli
Prime Minister that it was NATO the
United States in other words that
prevented
a truce from being signed between Russia
and Ukraine last year
as Joe Biden said that a lie Mitch
McConnell clapped and smiled wearing his
Ukraine flag tie
but maybe the most egregious lie is one
that affects every American Biden
claimed that our economy could not be
doing better because he's an economic
wizard watch this
we're a better position than any country
on Earth right now but we have more to
do but here at home inflation is coming
down here at home gas prices are down a
dollar fifties from their Peak food
inflation is coming down not fast enough
but coming down inflation has fallen
every month for the last six months
so those were very specific claims about
the economy a lot of which is easy to
measure subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight